shout out to the island
it's your brother
h3
booyah
big up boss man bitin
oh jesus
dude this is such a sick drop
shout out to the wendy
to the windy island man
h3 tv is back it's monday we are here to
party have some laugh have some good
times it's great to see you guys
how was everybody's weekend
good
excellent maybe you're always up to
something what'd you do this weekend uh
me ian cameron sam and lena went to a
movie at a cemetery that was pretty cool
went to watch blade oh
yeah that is cool
it's kind of wild people were like
taking photos blade yeah that's the
first time we watched it one of the
greatest stacks we've ever seen oh yeah
you've never seen blade yeah wait people
were taking photos of you no they were
taking pictures like next to like graves
and stuff next to like mausoleums that's
what they're called but yeah it was at
the hollywood forever cemetery it's a
yeah um excuse me don't you need the
dead's consent to uh it is a bit odd
that they do this big event it's this
has been a thing in l.a is it like an
october spookfest kind of issue they
actually do it year-round
right wendy's like they're died but i
imagine they're showing movies like
blade and probably i mean they are dead
but like if that was my fav my beloved
father's grave
and there was some p and a b was sitting
there like or zack was like you know
taking [ __ ]
putting cigarettes out on his grave
hashtag spooky season
just saying
anyway thank you to our sponsors today
meundies policy genius babble
and hello fresh
and don't forget teddy fresh i'm wearing
the new
uh
hoodie that comes out this thursday a
collaboration with the legendary
yuri
i
don't remember how our last name has
pronounced
sekia i think but i want to make sure i
say it right
here it is here's a little sneak preview
drop today comes out this thursday 10
a.m
yeah seki up uh 10 a.m
whoops
bst oh work it girl oh
i love this shirt by the graphics so
nice
work it work it work it work it work it
yep exciting tough thank you thank you
thank you
thank you dougie
yeah um
man there's some great stuff here i love
h3tv it's so loosey-goosey there's no
expectations
you know it's no oh we gotta talk about
this no here's straight up keemstar
complaining about my channel is dying
let's just watch this
i don't even know what this is this is
kind of the fun thing
about h3tv
all right keem hit me with it keemstar
your channel is dying well first of all
in the world issues are working right
we've run multiple tests but not only
this layer wait this is his house
it looks like he's at a bowling alley
like in a bad way
are you sure i think he's out of the bar
he hangs out yeah it looks like a bar
but maybe he has a bar he has like a bar
type set up at his house i believe
a bar
you guys are pretty familiar with the
the inner workings yeah we have the
blueprints we have the blueprints we
know all right well let's see here i'm
basically listen
wait wait what say it again i'm
basically hitler
what what
i didn't ask but uh
well
since you said it
i'll allow it i don't really relate to
the youngins anymore it's not because
i'm old
all right
it's so you
kids
are [ __ ] lame all right the new
audience the young kids the gen z
wait gen z's lame you have a fake
fireplace behind you
it's a screen with a fire on it
that is this place it's called the keem
bar
oh no
how many poor girls have gone down to
the king bar never came back up
[ __ ] a cringe fest
canceling people for all different
[ __ ] reasons they're making up
[ __ ] new rules they're entitled they
think they're thinking
here's another shot of keemstar am i out
of touch
no it's the children who are wrong
exactly
everything they're all a little bunch of
attention [ __ ] freaks on twitter it's
ratio or you fell off or some [ __ ]
cringe [ __ ] like it's like dork world
like straight up [ __ ] nerdville and
celebrate it for being a [ __ ] cringe
fest right celebrating each other for
being [ __ ] losers
it's unreal we've i've never lived in a
[ __ ] time like this in 13 years this
is the lamest [ __ ] anyone's ever had to
[ __ ] experience and quite frankly
it's not fun gen z is so lame why why do
you only date them
that's actually a valid question yeah
you don't seem to have a problem not
even a joke yeah
i'm serious yeah
i mean keemstar's been cancelling people
since the dawn of time he's such a liar
keemstar shut up yeah
you're canceling youtubers watching
right stupidest [ __ ] [ __ ] to the
point where the youtubers are walking
around like [ __ ] commercials like hi
guys i love you
i love you guys so much
nobody speaks their mind and if no one's
going to speak their mind then there
isn't going to be a counterpoint to
someone speaking their mind does that
mean he loves us because we're out here
speaking our mind let him know
especially keemstar well if he just
appreciates us speaking our minds so
much why is he always complaining to
susan about it he says he wants free he
says he wants people to speak openly but
when people do speak openly he writes
the emails to susan complaining hey
don't speak openly about me
do you think he
do you think okay i want to make the
joke
i'm not even going to go there there
isn't going to be dick he's watching
this like a hawk debate back and forth
which means there's gonna be
entertainment
you know i remember on drummer back in
the day we'd go through
20 tweets back and forth between two
creators fighting over something [ __ ]
stupid and it was [ __ ] hilarious and
awesome but you're never going to see
that again
such a dumb because of you little cancel
culture [ __ ]
i don't care though
be the craziest [ __ ] on the
planet be the cringiest generation
that's everlasting
you're the
i'm still gonna be me i don't care if
any of you [ __ ] watch wow because
eventually the culture will change again
and i will thrive and i'll remind
everyone what a bunch of losers you were
yeah when they could not yeah so when
the culture changes what's he going to
be like 60 65.
i'll be still being me baby we're
rocking that drama sometimes
things aren't that [ __ ] deep
right i think you're just [ __ ] out of
touch bro
yeah well keemstar acts like cancel
culture never existed
and you know sometimes keemstar things
aren't that [ __ ] deep right
deaf noodles i was watching deaf noodles
and uh god bless that man he has he's
the only man who hates keemstar as much
as i do i'd say
possibly more
well maybe i wouldn't go that far but i
love she's like it really [ __ ] excuse
me yeah maybe more i don't know maybe he
does hate him more but i love him for
that
and his what's cool is his audience has
a high tolerance for
slander like sometimes you talk a dog
people go i'm [ __ ] sick of it shut up
sorry and i'm like i'm not even getting
started yet
but with deaf noodles for some reason
his audience can't get enough of it
but he dug up this clip here
because they're a bunch of gen z cancel
culture uh uh
loving he's just humans just like
keemstar says dan he's just speaking his
mind
anyway here's
here's what uh death noodles had a great
point about this
i am basically calling out keemstar on
his [ __ ] hypocrisy now albeit in the
nearly 10-minute commentary that i make
about keemstar's hypocrisy there's about
30 seconds where i call out the fact
that he literally says the hard r in the
video but that is nowhere even close to
being the focus of my commentary so for
this person to frame my entire
commentary in that video as me reaching
all the way back to 2015 to try to get a
gotcha moment on keemstar rather than
just the comparison of what keemstar is
alluding to in his [ __ ] video talking
about his point or if they just wanted
to get some likes on twitter but they
better [ __ ] file some kind of
it's a threat there's so much keemstar
slender i can't even keep up with it but
there's a point can you maybe you can
find it instead of me browsing a video
live where he came starts reading out
all the sponsors of uh
contrast that with what keemstar did
back in 2015
being basically the head of castle
culture by gathering tweets from the
last two years from this gaming
organization calling out sponsors and
then trying to basically get the
sponsors to drop them the entire video i
am basically calling out keemstar on his
[ __ ] hypocrisy now albeit in the
nearly 10-minute commentary that i make
about keemstar's hypocrisy whatever
[ __ ] [ __ ]
dumbass
but i'm the number one supporter of
cancel culture all right there's some
great videos i wanted to watch right off
the bat
first of all i want to watch jordan
peterson crying about man
this one is just
man
jordan's down bad dude because i saw
this and well i guess it's doing really
well on
on tick tock it has 240 000 likes and
it's got a red pill red pill knowledge
is the name
of the song
i didn't feel very red felt i just felt
like
let me just play it i mean this guy's a
mess bro oh black pill
yeah this is blackville bro this is like
one minute away from elliot rodriguez
anyway what the hell are we gonna do
without men
you look around the city here you see
all these buildings go up these men
they're doing impossible things they're
under the streets working on the sewers
they're up on the power lines in the
storms and the rain they're keeping this
impossible infrastructure functioning
this thing that works in a miraculous
manner so and first of all he starts
with this proposition that like i guess
people want to
exterminate men
right i was going to comment on that
like the opening line what are we gonna
do
what the hell are we gonna do without
men he watched uh that why the last man
show and just like went on a rant
so first of all he's saying okay there's
people that want to kill all men and
then he goes thank you to our brave
let me hit that and voice right thank
you no
thank you to our brave
what the hell are we going to do with
our men
you look around the city here you see
all these
buildings when they're doing impossible
things they're under the streets working
on the sewers they're up on the power
lines and the storms and the rain
they're keeping this impossible
infrastructure women do all these things
you know i just realized what the music
playing the piano is like a slow sad
piano version of the skyrim theme no
[ __ ] kid
and they called it they called it
red pill knowledge baby
i wasn't sure at first but just listen
to it carefully right there i'm like 99
sure that's the skyrim music
functioning epic this thing that works
in a miraculous manner
they work themselves
to death
if you love men so much why don't you
have sex with one
very
it's
very
useful to you he starts crying everyone
not just men that they have well you
love men an important role to play you
necessary role and that if they
act properly and honestly and
forthrightly that
they can put their lives together and
they can help their families
and they can make their communities
better and that that's not toxic
masculine
calling phrases
he ends by saying talk something about
toxic
that a toxic maxilla needs a vile phrase
i mean clearly he's never watched nelk
yeah jordan peterson for sure half
center holy [ __ ]
for sure oh what are we going to do
without men
you know
who who's gonna
without men there'd be no bridges
there'd be no swords can you hit me with
some skyrim music
wait is there another jordan peterson
crying emotional video oh there is
i don't believe he's crying in this one
but he's very
wait here let's watch this
before i go into my tirade wait hold on
a harmless man is not a good man
i have a good man my favorite man was
ted bundy
ted bundy killed a lot of women he was
not harmless
my second favorite man was the zodiac
killer
dangerous man who has that under
voluntary control
civilized and disciplined right and who
can use that in the service
family a harmless man is not a good man
a harmless man is is a civilized got to
do without men what are we going to do
now you can hit me with something
from the city here you see all these
buildings go up
[Music]
it was that slowing down
no not this one but this is the main
theme i thought that was funny
okay
okay yeah what are we gonna do without
men
no this this is i need it needs to be
more
i can find that actual song there's more
anger more anger
this one's okay
what are we gonna do without men
we won't have any bridges
we won't have any roads
we won't have any cars
we won't have airplanes
we will we won't have any houses
we won't have any
damn
chairs to sit
we wouldn't have any beds
without men
damn
it what are we gonna do
damn it it's okay to be a man
and to build and to make rugs
at the
big swimming pools
[Music]
my favorite my favorite
[Laughter]
traditionally men have been the most
discriminated
class of prospective people
[Music]
i mean up until it was only up until one
month ago that men could just could
force other women to keep a baby
thank you men
why is he in like a gutter because he
was talking about the sewer the sewer
yeah what are we gonna do without men in
the sewers
what are we going to do without men in
the sky
[Music]
i had sex with men i dream about men i
think about men in my dreams
i am married to a woman but sometimes i
imagine she's a man because men are
better
and their bodies are so tight
and hairy which i like
and i like that and i like the peter so
i can't lie
what would i do what would do without a
penis
[Music]
yeah vaginas are fine but it's nothing
without a penis to go on i am delivered
i sometimes fantasize about putting a
penis in my mouth
i can't lie because i love men
and
it's not gay either it's just a way of
honoring men
with the world would be nothing without
[Music]
doesn't that make you gay
no it doesn't make me gay i just i'm
just imagining a world without being
i mean there's like a whole
sub genre of women crying to this video
yeah
it's all over okay wait i didn't
[Music]
[Music]
and the in the rain they're keeping this
impossible infrastructure functioning
this thing that works and miraculous
that's a miracle they work themselves
they work themselves
everyone not just men
they have
an important role to play
a necessary role in that if they
act properly
the point he's making is
and
it's such a natural fact to everybody
not like that men are so [ __ ] but
like nobody's
wanting to kill men
i just don't get it but he's he's making
it sound like that that's why it's
all red pill nation you know you get
that crotch rod they can put their needs
together they can help their families
what will we do with that they can make
their communities
better and that that's not
toxic masculinity
an appalling phrase that apology men
they're doing impossible things they're
under the streets working on the suit
you're [ __ ] so lost bro
i feel like he's
down
for like
this
this guide all right let's see the real
guides just surprise me
but it's not because i'm guilty of
domestic violence i've never supported
what the [ __ ] is this
tick tock he says she says i'm not
guilty of domestic violence this has a
hundred likes
this tick tock game we did has cursed my
[ __ ] life forever
all right let's finish this because i i
don't know she never supports that right
do you support domestic violence
yeah i mean you're against it right
oh
she's i beat the freaky chicks and all
of that
i didn't put it on man
i never asked for that video
jesus
i was having a good old time with jordan
peterson
all right let's go back
did we have other ones yeah i sent
another duet just for the latest
discord
oh [ __ ] it's turning into the whole
it's it's sweeping the nation i mean uh
the speech without men
you look around the city here you see
all these buildings go up these men
they're doing impossible things they're
under the streets
working on the sewers they're up on the
power lines and the storms and the rain
they're keeping this impossible
infrastructure
functioning
this thing that works in miraculous
manner
they work themselves
to death
so often literally it's
very
useful to tell
everyone not just men no they have to
tell everyone
an important role to play
a necessary role in that if they
act properly and honestly and
forthrightly
they can put their lives together and
they can help their families
dog stop tick-tock
i don't even know why it does that and i
can't go back like what the hell
[Music]
i just want all men i i could do this
all hour i don't know if people are over
it but
[Music]
it's awesome
i [ __ ] love this video so much
it just showed up on my homepage this
morning
let's read the comments hey what the
hell are we going to do with men
[Music]
what are we going to do without men
what are we going to do without
what in the country club is this
it's not easy only women children and
dogs are loved unconditionally whereas a
man is only loved under the condition
that he provides something
bro do you know what year it is i'm
pretty sure like
almost 100 100 of all households both
parents work
uh you can hear the emotions voice a man
truly fighting for us
this is a bad fighting for me
where would we be without beautiful hard
bodies
[Laughter]
he's devolved he's in the sewer
where is a man
i'm stuck in a sewer it was too deep
jordan go by i'm stuck in a sewer
somebody call the man to come get me out
of here it's poopy water you can't be in
here
oh i see a woman no no send a man i
don't need i don't want help from a
woman i'm deep undercover
oh what the hell it goes even deeper
here he is as super saiyan during his
speech
we've met some of your fans
and we got the impression they were all
male fans that the ones that we talked
to
um and that they were struggling with
their manhood and that you uh give them
this message that it's okay to be a man
it's not okay it's necessary
it's not okay how are we gonna do
without men
you look around the city here you see
all these buildings go up these men this
is horrible wait
that was
that was the lead-in oh my god this
whole time i was like in the back of my
mind i was like well we don't know the
context and like she said you know maybe
he's responding to a specific instance
but
that makes it so much more sensitive
these men they're doing impossible
things they're under the streets i don't
know who you're talking about i just
play video games and sit here all day he
goes look at these men doing impossible
things and then there's people at home
like you talking about me
oh
i love this one at the store somebody
some i love men so much sometimes i go
down to san francisco
what's the area where all the gay bars
are
in san francisco yeah
yeah
baby's on it
i love ben so much sometimes i go down
to the castro
ding dong san francisco and i have
nipple clips on under my suit
that's a little surprise for the men
so then will we take each other home and
honor men that we love so well
san fran is no joke man
you could pick up a man and show your
love to a man and just the first in the
first moment you step in there
and he takes my nipple clamps off
and i put his his home
and i say the world was built by men and
i'm going to build your will by with
this man's
oh my god
that's why i love men so much
all right we've been on this topic long
enough
yeah probably
oh wow oh
wow
what a voice
what a voice
the other one i wanted to watch was the
island boys is that at the top it's not
at the top it's
it's got a section uh
if you scroll down the worst rap duo of
all time okay yeah these ones these ones
exciting me
where did i see this did one of you guys
send this in chat
i lit oh i saw it on twitter i think
hassan tweeted it out yeah i saw it
yesterday
from this tweet
okay so this is actually a viral thing
yeah
florida ain't a real place
are you guys ready for some island wrap
these are white dudes right i mean i
mean i mean i guess i mean yes but like
they look like it's hard to tell there's
just so much going on it's a little bit
ambiguous
but i think if the geez
yeah maybe you could get a bio
i tried to look them up earlier
and all i could find was that they're
from florida which doesn't really tell
you what ethnicity they are but
all right well here guys is the sound of
the hot new thing baby
cause i'm an island boy and i've been
trying to make oh are my eyeliners
i am just island boy
i'm gonna just island boy i'm gonna get
kiwi
you're gonna keep that gun i'll be just
staring at the sun
full gazing i'm like oh i'm staying
they're like you wanna
they're cuban oh they're cuban so
they're island boys i guess that would
make that be true yeah cuba is an island
because i was like these [ __ ]
never been to jamaica
because that's usually what the island
is right
well especially
culture with the accent they're doing
yeah yeah but i was like don't i was
like the only island these guys are from
is like staten island
yeah like a wild one mine trying to make
it to the tall but my island by i've
these guys are the real deal i don't get
it
florida has a large jamaican population
as well
these guys aren't jamaican bro
i ironically think that kind of sounds
good dude me too i didn't want to say it
i don't think it sounds that bad no it
sounds really good thank you love you
put yourself out there so that you
you're i'm the real
it doesn't sound that bad i don't know
it's pretty good like i mean i
understand that they look goofy and the
whole thing is a weird vibe and they but
like it their voices are are pretty good
it sounded like he said poo stain at one
point though
love you're so right
go ahead
you guys were all talking big game
where's all the hate now shout out for
the island shout out to the island man i
think it's awful
i disagree i'm with love all the way i
think it's kind of slammer
well obviously it's a certain style but
their voices seem actually good
yeah fair enough do you want to watch
their uh do you want to watch a fully
produced song yes but first let me hear
where they said poo stain
because on island boy and i've been
trying to make you know what we don't
need to watch this again
yeah
somebody in the chat said a take is
based in island pilled
say what it's based in island pilled
based
an island built it totally is island
filled
you guys are mega island chat is saying
all right
yeah let's do it
i mean it's not even like you don't have
to like think it's is island boy abop
question yeah okay what do you think
love is that fair is island boy a bop
yeah yeah i think that's kind of a bop
dude all right
totally this yeah
island boy
it's jordan peterson plus island boy
i didn't buy
[Music]
yes oh
it's a let's go it's a box
60 percent saying it's a bop yo
the island boys are taking over the
nation right now
well let's let's kick it up a notch
let's watch let's watch what they all
right now together we're down with
island also you can't show the first
like four seconds of the video because
it literally opens with both of them
eating ass
for real yeah i'm not kidding for like
like five seconds and then the rest of
the video is fine but the first five
seconds they're eating ass
okay
i hate to break it to you guys
oh i see this is a joke this is
apparently a very important joke is that
they look like
cynthia from rugrats a cynthia doll
shout out to the island
[Applause]
um okay here is their music video so i
guess we'll have to maybe take another
poll after this one let me see this ass
eating situation i mean literally just
play it from the beginning on your
screen until it ends
oh wow
wow that's [ __ ] gross
what the [ __ ] i wish i could show you
guys this
it's just it's straight up a shot
here it's a shot there's literally girls
on all fours and they're and they're
here's the ass cheeks and they're like
going like this
it's crazy side by side
right
there's nothing i want to do
nothing i want to do with my twin
brother more than uh just eat ass that's
what it is
[Music]
[Music]
all right here we go
yeah the rest is fine okay so we're
gonna do another vote after the music
five minutes y'all really gonna make a
five minute music video
with like well you'll see we definitely
don't need to watch all five minutes
that's what i'm thinking already
can i point out something before we
start yeah so
ian if you cut back to the to the screen
of it okay so it's kodiak red
wicked way is the name of the song
featuring fly soldier so i've realized
one of them is kodiak red
and the other is fly soldier so he
featured his own brother that's part of
his band but i can't tell which one is
which they look exactly the same and
neither of them is more prominent in
this video whatsoever so i have no idea
and fly soldier it's featuring fly
soldier
got it
[ __ ] man [ __ ] your man
[Music]
they look like hello lost
[Music]
so the one with the eagle on his
i don't know i think it's virus
does this song start any time
okay are you allowed to do that as a
cuban
they look pretty white to me
these guys are dropping n-bombs that's
pretty wild
[Laughter]
you can never take away island boy for
me they need to do the mtv unplugged and
they'll be successful that's true
they're like typing where all of a
sudden he goes unplugged and was like
these guys have beautiful voices
it's the oddity and that kills
[ __ ] with your damn take your
thoughts and it's a must we be going
like a cuddle put it on your butt but we
put it on your model we don't do this
[ __ ] until they sitting like a slammer
go out all my time until you really
gotta say something keep it with him
impeccable bro i can't even find the
lyrics on google
nobody's been up with the decipher the
lyrics yeah
it's
[Music]
and go back like hit left on the arrow
key to go back just a second and just
let it play right here hold on
i'm sliding all day
[Music]
pause
why does he have his hand on his
brother's chest
it's his shoulder no no that's on his
pecs
because he loves man
weightlessness
where will we be without men and
brothers
i mean it's probably not that bad it's
not quite on his
breast
is it
i don't know man
that looks like chest to me we do know
they eat ass together so
they share everything brothers that eat
ass together stay together
you're gonna get all these memes coming
in oh hold on guys we have a sewer
update
uh jordy peterson has been joined by the
island boys oh no
love island
we need a man down here to save us in
the sewer i'm trapped down here with the
island boys yeah that makes sense
because they look like they crawled out
of the store
the island boys have been telling me
about the problems they've had with
being men
and i want these island boys to know
that you can build
towers
and do electricity
and i want the island boys to know that
you can have a family and you can mean
something to that family
and i want these island boys to know
what are you laughing at well you but
then i look over the chat and people are
spamming brussy because they're broken
wait what's a pressy
okay wait
brother
okay cause
brussy
i want these brothers to know that
they're brushies
are valid
[Music]
dude
i know you're not laughing at me that
hard
[Laughter]
i very much
i [ __ ] love the island boys man
i want these island boys to know that
their brushes are valid and as a man
i want to tear that brussey up
about island
i think that island brussels is one of
the most beautiful things about man
island brussy for sure
[Music]
i love the sewer updates
all right well let's let's venture on a
little bit further
like you're looking so bad i didn't
really want you i like your coochie
[Music]
suddenly in this music video they just
start cutting in
them seemingly like at a bar being shot
by a camera
with like mini dv tapes from like 2001
it's well they're how old are they they
look like 16.
yeah they're way too young for these
kind of cameras nobody knows who they
are come on now
if you like me i don't give a [ __ ] how
you feel yeah yeah i'm on the top on the
top on the top yeah i'm way too clean
way too clean you can knock me down on
me down let me down yeah why you gotta
frown on your fight cause i don't know
why but i've been gone
do you know their age
is
wait isn't a wigger a white dude i think
they're saying wicked way that's the
name of the song right right
i'm seeing 20 years old on this website
those guys are 20.
they look younger
yeah i'm sure this guy's a fan bro
this homie here is a big fan of the
island boys
it looks like they're at a bowling alley
ladies if you ever get invited to keem
keem's bar in his house say no
i cannot emphasize this enough
downright money money
all right you know what i don't want to
remember the island boys this way
should we do another poll yeah let's do
another poll but like what's the
question how do we phrase what should we
just say
do you still like the island boys or how
about this no is island boy still a bot
through the lens of the music island
boys still a bomb
after hearing wicked way how about that
yeah and while you while you wait let me
play it again is island boys still a bop
after hearing wicked way
oh
81 no
so really i voted yes
well me too all right
i'm sticking to island boys being above
sixteen percent
damn brutal
that's up to 23. i still think it bob
say i thought [ __ ] bob didn't survive
we've been singing it at the office all
morning so yeah i walked in i heard you
i was like whoa you know about that
video
yeah i've been cracking up about it
since last night
why so many people download the video
the island boys stands
down vote what video
rh3tv
if i had to guess
uh our tardiness
okay that's fine it could be that i
accept that that could be unless we had
a bunch of island boys in the chat i
accept the
do they usually downvote for tardiness i
feel like we've been late before don't
get dislike bomb i accepted
we were very late okay
i'm sorry guys you you downvote away
i accept it
you know
whoa has it been 30 minutes somebody
just set off a bomb yeah it's been 40
actually let's do some ads boy let's
just do two
yeah we're gonna thank our sponsors
yeah
we're gonna start
compared to pumpkin patch photo shoots
and costume planning shopping for life
insurance with policy genius can be one
of the easiest tasks on your october
to-do list
what makes policy genius
an absolute necessity well i'll tell you
it makes it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top insurers
all of all in one place and why should
you even compare because you could save
50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius you
could save 1 300 or more per year on
life insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies it's not just life
insurance it's all all insurances that
you currently uh use
they've got licensed experts at policy
genius that work for you not the
insurance companies so you can trust
them to help you navigate every step of
the shopping and buying process and that
kind of services and policy genius
thousands five-star reviews across
trustpilot and google
and eligible applicants can get covered
in as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes advisor hire
then the scumbag competitors over at
ladder
at ethos and bet and bisto
bestow
[ __ ] them
their dumbass name
here's how it works getting started is
easy you know what's easy to say policy
genius that is easy
you know what else is easy getting
started first head to policygenius.com
h3tv in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and scheduling for free
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
so head on over to policygenius.com
h3tv to get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice to get it right thank you thank you
[Music]
uh you have a
what is bed patrol someone wrote you a
letter
yeah it was somebody
a long time member in the channel and um
we shouted them out last htc tv i
believe while you were in the bathroom
okay and um
and they sent me a certificate of title
really yeah
i guess i'll read the letter yeah
all right well you want to hit you want
to pipe in is this an emotional letter
is this a
triumph no i'm not really sure i i guess
triumphant maybe
yeah
daniel
on tuesday the 12th of october at
approximately
150 and 20 seconds in the afternoon i
the bed patrol spent five dollars on the
live show titled kim kardashian screamed
at me in the streets of new york city i
think the title has probably changed
like five times i think that's the
final yeah okay
to send an important message
i had paid for this message is part of
my duty as the bed patrol
to me it was crucial that all viewers
understand that a tanning bed is indeed
not a bed
i expected this is uh in reference i
assumed to the girl who pooped in the
tanning bed correct
i expected the message to be read out
received understood and for the show to
move on what happened surprised in
enlightenment you confidently and
without hesitation stated that i am one
of your favorite discord members
really what do you know about them all i
know so their name is bed patrol yeah
and the only thing i ever see them do in
there is when ever somebody
says that they're uh they should really
go to bed
or something
uh they pop in and um
and police them and say go to sleep god
i need this guy in my life yeah
give him my personal phone number would
you
okay
[Laughter]
what happened to uh you confidently and
without hesitation stated
that i am one of your favorite discord
members and that you appreciate what i
do for the community it was those words
that changed everything i truly wasn't
prepared for such beautiful sweet words
to come out of your elegant silver
tongue whoa you see it was at this
moment i saw it i needed to find where
you lived camp outside your window and
watch your every movement oh no
that's not written
i saw it
let love rule
okay
i saw it in your big glistening bright
eyes i saw it in the surprise childlike
gasp
i saw it in the gleeful silky smooth
voice as you interrupted a b
sorry
you daniel you are not a hater
oh let me guess who did you put this in
and said absolutely 100 must read and
bolded it
is that what it said in the doll yeah it
says
certified included a certificate
included is that the top of the document
though
um why people call you a hater i will
never understand dan you wrote this
letter be honest i did not
for what you said about me on that
fateful tuesday will forever keep my
heart warm with your graceful words
maybe reminisce about all the superb
memories between you me and the discord
like when you gave me that fantastic
profile picture of the pokemon called
jigglypuff
when you confirmed that i was the new
co-host
i don't think that happened but
oh maybe jokingly i don't know and when
you panicked because you thought i had
left the server
okay uh
you get the idea yeah
oh
god here's the certificate you want to
get this um dan the lover huh yeah is
that what you're trying to do trying to
get that out laminated i'm done to get
it framed let's go oh my god
you want to be called dan the lover now
just dance okay
[Music]
i don't need a title dude
[Music]
oh let's check calls i haven't looked at
calls today let's see
yeah there's somebody i saw
that um
went to that elk party that uh really
at uh
was it in illinois
one of a few that got shut down but that
was definitely the one that made the
headlines uh thinking about getting
hairline surgery i don't see anyone here
talking about milk maybe they left oh
maybe they dropped does this sound
interesting
um let's see frankie
frankie i'm a little interested in your
anecdote but i am hesitating to believe
you at face value
yeah i mean i have some contacts context
here if you'd like it
yeah why don't you set us up
yeah so i don't know if you remember a
few weeks ago
you guys were having a conversation
about kids who would work like 30 35
hours a week
um that was me at my
local bowling alley in like po dunk
bumble woods pa
and uh we had like the weirdest
amalgamation of people coming in all the
time we've had furries
uh we'd have like old dudes bringing in
girls so young to like keemstar would
blush
of course
and so
the worst of all of it though
was midnight bowling i would work
10-hour shifts after
like doing a friday in high school
and on this one particular night this
douche bag like alpha male alpha brain
guy who i went to high school with came
with all of his buddies they were drunk
and they were just like being
belligerent and uh
i was at the counter and he comes up and
he's like hey dude uh how big are the
bowling pins
and i showed him one and he was like
cool cool
so then the rest of my passions people
are starting to leave
and like i see his group
leave without him and so i'm
going around cleaning the place up i go
behind the machines to turn them off
and as i'm there i noticed the door is
like open and i get hit with like this
subtle
wafting stench
of pure ass and i turn the corner and
he's sitting on the sides one of the
machines trying to put a bowling pin
like in his butt no
why did i know that 100 bricks going
literally like pants around his ankles
and this and he was like he was like the
most homophobic racist dude at the high
school
big jock
you know bullet the whole caboodle
that's so interesting and then the worst
part is
the worst part is he's drunk he turns he
looks me he goes it's this big and then
i leave i leave the room wait so he he
referenced your previous conversation
instead of being like freaked out
uh yeah he was uh
a very simple man to say the least like
very unself aware
so plus i think he was so wasted
he was just trash oh my god so yeah he
was absolutely polite
wow it's so interesting like an
interesting kind of
fetish i guess though to wait for all
your homies to leave and then go back
and shove a bowling pin up your ass well
they had like that they had like that
alpha brain testosterone running the
whole night like flinging six pound
bowling balls down the lane it was an
absolute mess
now i know on the east coast uh you know
they have candlestick bowling was this
candlestick or was this uh was just
no no this was like
regular 10 standard standard 10 pin oh i
would
it he i'm assuming he had the he had
this yeah go ahead
i i do not know the answer that question
i wasn't trying to really
inspect i was going to ask him like hey
man how's it going so far you know i was
i was doing that
yeah
what is this you're showing me
there's no way that's real
yeah i was just trying to set a visual
for you guys no way it's an x-ray
is this a real x-ray
i hope not i hope not too because that
looks too small i agree that's why i was
but no i don't think
i don't think there's some i think you
could probably
put the tip of a bowling pin up the ass
not the whole thing obviously i mean it
gets pretty bulbous pretty quickly you
know it's like yeah yeah yeah well you
obviously have to be a size queen to you
consider that dude that's going to
really like
tipping it in to say the least he was
just starting his endeavors
what happens now you're you bounce but
like you guys just lock him in there
tell me what happens
no no so i was with my uh like napoleon
complex short super conservative boss
and this guy was like you know like the
notre dame fighting irish logo
like that was his persona so i ran back
and he's like putting away pretzels and
i'm like hey you need to check behind
the machines
there's something happening there and i
don't know what to do with it
and so he said he said i'll take care of
it and then literally he leaves and he's
in there for a long time like like a
prolonged period of time now
i don't think that
what happened is the implication of that
but i do think that when he left uh the
guy was like
walking out with his head hung and like
he had like his jacket like
hanging out his waist and he looked like
he's got turned down from a date the the
bowling pin buckeye like he was very
depressed
and and and do you know what happened to
the pin the particular pin after
and go back into rotation
we put it in circulation for kids
birthday parties no they got rid of it i
don't know
i'm just asking questions here no
we hung it up and then whenever anyone
pulls 300 they would slap it for good
luck
i think they [ __ ] it i think it was
gone and did you ever see that guy again
sober or or was he gone forever did he
move to a new town you did
so no i went to high school with them
and uh i had my senior year cut short by
covid
um and so like i only had seen him a few
times the remainder of the year before
uh
before like i never saw him again but in
those moments i would see him walking
down the hallways and he would like look
at me and like immediately cut left like
anything he needed to do to stay away
from me
yeah he's a size queen my friend
[Laughter]
yeah i'm not no no no no no no no no no
no i'm just kidding don't do that i'm
totally i'm also kidding
well thanks for the call that was a
fantastic story i really appreciate you
staying there can i tell you guys really
quick that you guys are heroes you talk
about feats and farts
and all [ __ ] other things but like
you guys keep me going through any heart
thank you brother everyone else going
so like
salute to you
girlfriend of six years is on the line
so maybe answer her call as well
she is okay okay we'll definitely do all
right thanks brother you take care
thanks for the story
all right bye guys thank you see that
was a good call right does everyone
agree
that was a good call people are saying
best calling so far i think
i'm just saying
good calls are possible you guys don't
hate
don't kill
the whole call genre we're we're forging
onward it's just gonna get better with
time we're getting better at this thing
we know it's going to be rough for a
while but um
it'll be worth it it'll be worth it
yeah that's pretty interesting that he
telling you these macho
alpha bros they take pins up the ass
there's a reason why they're also like
like uh they joke about being gay to
them it's like one big joke
i'm not he's like
or that one guy from now was i guess
steve will do it does those jokes all
the time it's like dude you're gay
like it's fine
it's fine dude when he when he told that
i just think about the sheer utter pain
of
someone putting a bowling pin clearly is
people are in pleasure my dude like
proctologist status like it's
yeah i mean an [ __ ] rips like this
baby thank you for the definition of
size queen
did you not know what that meant i
didn't know there's a few people back
here who aren't sure so for real a size
queen is a slang for a man or woman who
prefers a sexual partner with a large
penis [ __ ] size queen
[Applause]
someone aka someone that would never
date me thank you
hey you know what i heard actually on
the radio on the way in this morning was
that our boys uh
our boys uh
uh what is it chad and jt
oh the party bros the party bros yeah
they were on
the radio like the local radio station
here in la promoting i think this
weekend
they are having a rally at pershing
square downtown l.a for um for small
dongs
a rally for small dogs
dongs oh small dong rally right remember
that's like one of those yeah that's
certain thing so if you want a a small
dong rally downtown l.a
um
let me see if
i can find some info maybe some poopa
troopers would want to participate in
that
well in the meantime as dan uh
gets that information
uh
let's see let's try to get another good
caller on the line
thinking about getting hair surgery it's
kind of good when i don't read it out
because it keeps you interested right
you guys want to hear
needs advice on asking for a raise i
like giving advice let's see
maybe i can help vanessa out
vanessa can i how can i help you
hi um
so i work in a very similar field maybe
a production
and i've been working for this company
for about three years
and i like to think i'm a pretty hard
worker i keep my head down and with this
specific company we have extremely low
wages
which was fine because my job was like
really chill at first but then
um like i said i'm kind of a hard worker
so i got like promoted and i took on
more responsibilities and i got a small
raise with that about two years ago
and now
um
so making i'm just gonna be honest i'm
making 15.50 an hour
what state do you live in
sorry what'd you say what state do you
live in
i live in california in los angeles
that's pretty isn't that the minimum
wage isn't the minimum wage 15
it might be yeah
it's 15. did it get raised to 15. i mean
it was 12.50 what the [ __ ] did they
raise you from
yeah so i got a bump when i got promoted
and i'm pretty sure that was just
because the minimum wage was raised
and then i got it right
but i'm also taking on like producing
and like a whole bunch of other
responsibilities because we're short do
you work for a big super wealthy company
i would say it's like mid-size it's
definitely not small
i don't here's the thing i know that
this industry like isn't there like a
huge uh protest right now where people
walking out and [ __ ] well that's right
that's that's uh union most yeah
you're not in the union in our like
the field i'm in it's
news production we are not okay
yeah so unfortunately production in los
angeles is one of the most highly
exploited group of workers because
they know people want to work in this
field and they take advantage of that
and uh there's no [ __ ] reason for you
to be making 15 dollars an hour period
uh it just doesn't make sense that's
like free [ __ ] labor for them i don't
know how much money they make i don't
know what's their situation but i don't
think you're gonna get yourself a raise
because these companies just thrive on
exploiting labor i don't know i mean
have you asked your boss for a raise oh
sorry say that again have you asked your
boss for a raise
no not yet and so and it's been
something i've been talking about for a
really long time and i got this
email this weekend when we asked for
extra help and they essentially were
like well get used to it
because this is how it is and that's
kind of why i was like well if i'm now
expected to do all this stuff i would
like to ask
for some more money um so
i'm my plan is and i guess my question
is
is that how should i approach it and how
much money should i ask for because i've
never
asked for a raise before every job i've
had before i've been like rewarded for
my hard work so this is my first time
i've ever felt like
exploited and i don't know
i would ask for what you want ask for a
lot more chances are they aren't going
to give it to you and you're going to be
at a crossroad there but uh vanessa
we wish you the best and i hope you get
that raised all right you give them hell
uh all right thank you for the great
advice i love you guys show
and good luck you guys get out there and
get on youtube and i'll tell you what
spit in their [ __ ] face for me yeah
definitely start open with that open
negotiation thank you
thank you vanessa
um
i think you're gonna get that girl fired
so sure enough uh
well if she takes my advice yeah
which
the small dog get that dan you can't
show that what are you talking about
remove it
from the screen
what was wrong
let's not talk about it okay hi i'm do
you not see what's wrong with it oh i
see it now i didn't notice that it's
it's subtle
that's very small bro i'm sorry
we went on this weird [ __ ] crusade
about the small donk thing and then
you're putting pictures of dongs on my
[ __ ]
screen like what the hell dude
i can't jerk off to this
right
jesus man why you so passionate about
the small dong rally dan you want trying
to go
i thought it was funny
i got a good laugh out of it
[Music]
i'm gonna come
raised mormon
i was uh the knelt party i mean how
interesting could a now party be
wants to sing you guys want to hear
someone sing our kelly passport probably
not
probably not
gonna go if they're a good singer or not
okay let's give them a shot you guys
just have your buttons ready you know
what i'm saying you guys you guys got
too
shy on the button
yeah i got canceled for being the only
one that uses it i know but it was a
funny meme just a b on the button yeah
whatever i don't care all right so jacob
we want to hear your rendition but i'll
warn you fingers are on the button
jacob
thank you jacob
dropped that call
all right let's move on
um
dude pickups whole car after doing a
popper this seemed to fake to me i saw
this on my feed
and it didn't look real what do you
think
[Music]
so i don't know why he does a popper is
that something that has to do with
weightlifting
is that like a sniffing salt or
something yeah yeah smelling salt to get
you jacked to lift weights i mean ian
ian does them right
we all did them yeah yeah all right yeah
we tried it
ian you still do sniffing salts no
why did you do that again
i don't know i was curious
i didn't lift the car though i also want
to point out the shirt he's wearing
yeah it's a bradley martin gym shirt oh
he's an elk boy
that's a full sand moment i don't think
he's lifting the car i think it's fake
i actually do think it's fake i don't
know this popper is a miracle drugs
i think there is
no [ __ ]
that he doesn't have the leverage to
pick it up what is this ant even holding
on to
you know what i mean
there's no way he has any lip unless
it's maybe it's on the roof
you know let me get a close look here
can we get a pole let's see i guess it's
it's on the roof or the handlebar like
the handle near the driver's side
i saw chris angel do this one
chris angel yeah and that guy's
everything mother of christ all right
let's watch it
what is this
no way
oh my god it's corn
okay
i guess it could be real i mean he's
just lifting half the car
but shout out to the now boys zoos you
know who lives at the zoo beasts
is it rona season
i don't know something about it looks
fake you guys i don't know
something about it doesn't look real
there's a cut here
what do you guys think
i think it's possible
yeah because he's not like
like me and a bunch of my friends push
the car once
like over to a different spot but we i
mean if someone's really buff i don't
know you mean like you put a car on
neutral and pushed it it wasn't in
neutral
he might my cousin was blocking the
driveway where he wanted to play
basketball he's being a dick
so my other cousin and his friends
pushed the car like legit sure that's
possible yeah was there a burning baby
in there by any chance or no
unfortunately all right well beast beast
uh beast zember i don't know
who's janice dickens do you guys know
who this is she roasted keemstar she's
like an actress and model i played right
everyone's
what is she doing with keemstar and this
guy uh such a weird world
supreme star oh you know her olivia
okay stop
okay uh first of all i want to say how
political uh elky good job at wearing
the pauly d merchandise t-shirt
uh second of all janice i'm a huge fan
of yours i play like
the villain of the internet in many ways
uh keemstar
and uh you play the villain on all your
reality shows which i absolutely love
because villains create the
entertainment the drama uh that's kind
of an insult right
like in the world like for example uh
jess up here not that she's trashy but
she's from jersey and that is the trend
right now and janice it's not really who
you find that's a superstar or not it's
just the fact that they're under your
belt because i'm sure you can make a
superstar out of anyone so even if the
industry frowns upon who you pick
the normal people like me and the others
here
will cheer on our champion
our jersey trash
can you do it what a pitch
can you do it
can you do it
can you do it
just speechless can you do it
speechless watch
and do it what what the [ __ ] does he
want me to do yeah
it's like a bumbling idiot
okay the guy's sitting there bumbling
he's the villain i started i started
building me up
in fact is the guy by the way him with
the shut up keemstar
shut up that's him by the way he goes
[ __ ] shut up [ __ ]
yeah this is a deep traumatic moment for
keemstar uh the volume is gone
how'd that happen
what happened there's no volume it
probably got muted
[ __ ]
yeah there it is
once joan collins was the first
villainess
you started building me on the internet
don't [ __ ] yourself
you know i don't care how
okay when you want to talk a really good
solid idea
and you want me to judge beauty and you
want me to judge
something iconic bring it on but
in the meantime go shave all that [ __ ]
around your face
it's not working
thanks
all right all right
she's like so annoyed oh that was
fantastic
i know keemstar cried after this yeah
i feel that
[ __ ]
jordan pearson be like all men are
important except keemstar [ __ ] that guy
get him back in the sewer with all of us
um
god i wish i could watch the jordan
peterson cries about men again for the
first time
so [ __ ] good
this is exorcism
it's a gentleman performing an exorcism
with a squirt gun
it's like a lazy ass dude he just
doesn't want to get up
i love this
yeah this dude just doesn't want to get
up that's just straight up like nerf
it's got like a
oh man
a willing participant for
sure what is going on george appears and
be like where would the world be without
men yo
is he dual wielding yeah he's dual
wielding
this girl is cursed as hell she needs a
double
where would the world be without men to
exercise women of their demons with nerf
squirt guns
that's right
oh the singing dude is back in queue all
right
that's fantastic
there you go man there's there's a spot
for everyone in this world if you never
thought you could
make a buck
exercising demons with a toy squirt gun
then you're not thinking hard enough
hallelujah that's a side hustle my dudes
this guy's actually like a
what would be a funny day job for him
bus driver i don't know
come home squirt some fools
oh for the priest yeah because he's got
a day job you know this is a side hustle
right let's see
what she goes for her feet at the end
watch she goes for her feet right here
he's like that [ __ ] stinks girl
[Music]
it's a shame because it looks like
there's some really interesting audio
well the singer's back so everybody
finger on the button
uh where's the singer is it just
yeah here it is all right um
jacob
polo
all right nathan my guy jacob my dude
thank you for calling we love you we
appreciate you
you i understand we wanted to sing where
our fingers are on the button
with peace and love oh you don't even
need that you're kidding me
that's on the performance of a lifetime
are you ready i don't want us to play
music music or if i should just go
acapella we
we can play the music for you
that would be even better go ahead zach
pipe it in queue him up
[Music]
all righty
whenever you're ready
go ahead jacob you just watch
i mean he was a good backing singer but
i understand yep no i liked what i heard
that's why i was like hold on let me
hear this go ahead can you please start
with i got this
yeah i want the full picture
whenever you're ready jacob
i'm so ready okay well then all right a
compelled time to start singing
do you have your passport oh did you get
your time
girl would you like to come back with
rise to america ow
america
america
the beautiful do you have your transport
did you get your shot
girl would you like to come back with
rob to america america america
america
to america
[Applause]
oh my god i'm sorry my name is home
i just gotta apologize to my nana all
right she did not deserve that but it's
okay that was good what are you talking
about that was glorious
you know do me scare her by a little bit
yo hit do this part again because the
phone couldn't even register the notes
do the part at the end the big flourish
where he goes america
like hit that for me one more time
because i couldn't quite
yeah
i need a sip of water hold on
that was powerful
beautiful it's just beautiful
i'm sorry gorgeous it doesn't wow i
gotta say i'm super impressed thanks for
calling in and nobody beeped you so damn
we'll see you on broadway take that show
on the road
our kelly i know he's a little quick on
the button but i appreciate it you know
i was gonna thank michael jackson for ap
but i didn't want to
go pushing down now i'm playing i got
age restricted on this video thank you
jacob all right stay well keep singing
keep singing
thank you don't you ever stop singing
never stop singing
where would the world be without men
singing
we'd be
nowhere
we'd be nowhere without men
where would the world be without men
proctologists
to check that your penis is healthy
or is that a butt doctor
without a proctol just to check for
prostate cancer prostate cancer where
would we be
where would we be
without doctors who are men all of them
where would we be without it's not easy
[Music]
where would we be
if it wasn't for big beautiful strong
men
who build buildings and sweat their
bodies glistening in the sun
where would we be
without big meaty [ __ ]
that just makes you feel full
[ __ ]
some have said that i'm a size queen i'm
not i'm a size king because i like men
he's like brett kavanaugh saying i like
beer i like
men
i like being your honor
[Music]
that was ours chad is saying that was r
kelly from prison apparently yeah
it did sound that good
[Music]
we drink beer senator do you like beer
senator i like men do you like men
senator
having some beers with friends
uh
[Music]
what else we got
is there any like do you guys have any
suggestions i want to watch like a long
content
con long form content like reaction [ __ ]
because we could do whatever the [ __ ] we
want here i i have a request but i don't
know if we're able to watch it it's
a j-station video i found
yeah that sounds fantastic we've seen
the gay potion this is okay wait hold on
lucy
our cousy
how they interrupt you for that one
thank you for that
but yeah in this video he drinks a
cartoon potion
and he becomes a cartoon yes
you guys want to watch r kelly
again
we never watch or sorry the machine gun
kelly oh the other kelly his cousin yeah
i'll tell you where we're from
machine gun kelly
you don't know about that no
let me show you an iconic tweet right
now
wait i
vaguely remember it
oh ian says you guys talked about it in
front of me once i vaguely remember it
but now i really do want to see it
uh let's see
it's an all-timer
i need a machine gun
listen guys if you're offended by
anything i said call in and discuss it
with me i'm i'm not hiding from anything
i said if you all want to talk about it
we can talk about it i'm not trying to
pretend like it didn't happen
and uh
that's it guys you know
i feel like there's different varying
degrees of
that's it i i don't know
but at least i never tweeted this
say what you will about me but i never
tweeted out
i wish 13 14 15 year old girls weren't
allowed to be so hot
the [ __ ] you say
13
13
so i wouldn't feel like such a creeper
when i look at them i'm still 19 i'm
just saying bruh 13
the [ __ ]
13 year old still got like lunch fails
and [ __ ]
13 y'all still got those barbie lunch
pills
okay well let's watch
me at a gq party fox i'll actually tell
that story right you said to me you
smell like weed and i said
i am weed
and then
sick
he loves that too
he brings it up probably every time they
talk about how they met
wow
you vanished
hi i'm megan fox hi i'm colson baker is
that your real name
sometimes
and this is
[Music]
okay yeah this is great this is the one
how many tattoos do i have looking for
name them out while you it's best to go
by your ankle back of your neck
the nietzsche
and then the one right below the one i
gave you which is the yin
yang that one doesn't count no that
doesn't count my other rib cage is also
tattooed that's what i said you only
said nietzsche in my bag all right well
count the other rib cage too that's nine
right
the bonus if you want to redeem yourself
is
what does my back tattoo say the one on
my channel
close you're in the vicin that's not
correct but do you know what it's from
oscar wilde no it's shakespeare
go for the butterflies go for it i know
you can do it butterflies
seems like they're really there's a
butterfly in there but that's not how it
starts
we
we
will all laugh at the butterflies with
gilded wings
so close we will all laugh at gilded
butterflies it's from king here and by
shakespeare okay what does the nietzsche
quote on my room say we are doing ap
literature class right now that is for
sure not okay you get
because you were close on the number
i'll give you one half of a point for
that but that was rough
what's something on my bucket list
be abducted by a ufo
i'll give you two points for that how do
you make that happen
i think she's already living with an
alien
or that's offensive sorry
extraterrestrial correct boop
a boop being a beep was it a it was a
beep or a boo boop right with boobs
from planet weed
right
two points
um what was my first acting role
oh mary kate and ashley
oh okay and oh the soap opera that you
won't let me watch if i swear to god if
you play clips from that play clips
i'll give you a point for that okay what
is my biggest pet peeve
when i eat
and i'm talking to you in your ear i
don't think it has to be related to you
specifically how would you do that huh
who does that eating
in someone's ear
that's not a thing that anyone does you
freak
quickly like just what's my picture yeah
but but that's
the sound of chewing gum yeah yeah
there's a name for that i have that what
was my favorite movie as a kid it's
really hard to decipher when like we
still watch
kid movies all the time
hook you stand by
okay i'll give you a point for that
what's my favorite movie now and if you
don't know this i'm going to be very
upset at you what's my favorite movie
now
i can't wait for it to get cold and i'm
going to make no no no no you don't you
don't have to you don't have to go there
it's like an eight series piece we're
talking about hairy [ __ ] potter
yes don't think that i'm not
i'm not into this video
i just want to point out the chat saying
ethan you eat in our ears all the time
right
i guess that's true
is there a certain part i should watch
because this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
boring
as a [ __ ]
i haven't actually watched this gem yet
anyone got a special moment
crying somebody's crying
no nobody's crying
well let me read the comments here
uh
i can't they're saying they have amazing
chemistry i can't watch this i'm out
where did the suggestion come from to
watch that well i think it was just the
weed moment
yeah i mean that was just in the article
i didn't know about this video this is i
am by
i want to go back to the vibes at the
beginning of the show
i smoke marijuana so i don't beat my
wife and children
men are important
we have we have so much responsibilities
we have to smoke weed just to not beat
our wife and children
it's hard being a man
we got two more ads oh [ __ ] let's do
them
this episode is sponsored by bab
made by men four men i'm just kidding
babble when you're traveling to a
destination where you don't know the
language it can be challenging to
accomplish even the simplest tasks
thankfully there's babel the number one
selling language learning app
through babel's bite-sized lessons
you'll learn new language skills that
can actually use in the real world from
greetings menus and directions to
gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture
babel is a travel essential
you said you did the the spanish one
then or
yeah i was trying to brush up on my on
my spanish uh a little bit the uh habla
espanol it's been a few years since i
worked spaniel
spaniel
yeah how was it
it was good it was good i mean i i
only spoke kitchen spanish from work in
a restaurant for years so it was nice to
expand the things that weren't directly
plate and fork related i feel that
well babel's 15-minute lessons make a
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
a.i
for the lesson plans but babel lessons
were created by over 100 language
experts and their teaching methods have
been scientifically proven to be
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel's
speech recognition their technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and accent
there are so many ways to learn from
babble in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts games videos stories and
even live classes start your new
language learning journey today with
babble
right now when you purchase a three
month battle subscription you're gonna
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use the promo
code h3tv that's b a b b e l dot com
code h3tv babble language for life thank
you thank you peace and love peace and
love
and finally thank you to hellofresh
you know him
you love him damn who made that
[Music]
uh
one of our fans that looks who sent it
to me fire
this was the maple mustard chicken legs
with mashed potatoes and nutty green
beans
i love my green beans nutty
easy
what is hello fresh hello fresh you get
pre pre-measured fresh ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
door this way you're gonna skip the
grocery store trips it's gonna make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why hello fresh is america's
number one meal kit here's how it works
they send you a refrigerated box with
like dry ice in it with all the
ingredients fresh perfectly laid out if
you don't know how to cook if you don't
know where you're around the kitchen
if you don't want to spend time
grocery shopping preparing hellofresh is
the way to go because you're going to
learn a lot about cooking if you don't
know how they're going to tell you
everything and it's pretty much
the funnest way to get into cooking and
your meals are guaranteed to be delish
that looks really good
damn come on now
um hello fresh isn't just for meals
their marketplace features a variety of
snacks too like this falls pumpkin
cinnamon rolls to get you in the mood
for cozy seasons
and you're going to get better value
hello fresh is over 30 percent cheaper
than grocery stores with pre
portioned ingredients then ensure you
won't spend money on excess food while
also saving you a shopping trip
uh
yep so guys go to hellofresh.com
h3tv14
and use the code
h3tv14 for up to 14 free meals feeding
america
including free shipping that's
hellofresh.com
h3tv promo code h3tv for 14 free meals
h3tv14
h3tv14
for 14 free meals
hellofresh.com h3tv14
thank you thank you
and it's in the description that's why
they're america's number one meal kit
love y'all
we're done done thank you to our
sponsors hey
yeah if
if machine gun kelly thinks he's weed
he's never seen uh
my relationship
ela said this is when me and ela first
met she said you smell like weed i said
i am weed so
damn
he doesn't know anything i'm the real
deal
daughter
yep
um
let's see what else we got here
you should watch this
you got something for me i do
maybe oh what what do we have to talk
about kanye you have something
what do you want to click bait kanye for
the kanye walking around wait you do
need to see the thing of kanye what the
haircut
they have no
there's a few there's a few items oh
yeah i would love to i love kanye memes
your deliveries here
yes but like give me the comment
what the [ __ ] bro
[Music]
your delivery is here my dude
wow i gotta see that again
oh jesus bro
oh no
oh man there's a lot of [ __ ] back there
you've got a washing machine like what
i think they were moving out or
something
oh [ __ ]
that sucks so bad
that reminds me i saw
i saw a video
of man if you go to um
idiots in cars i saw one recently that
was so good
i'm trying to find it it was someone who
was trying to help in a driveway
and they ended up rear ending
let me see if i can find it i mean these
are all good to be honest with you
what the [ __ ] bro look at this yeah what
don't [ __ ]
bags of gasoline in the trunk oh my god
oh my god
oh
what the [ __ ]
that's crazy i'm assuming that's from
the uk you know they're having like a
they have a petrol crisis oh really what
they call it
i don't know
i really understand why
some oh jesus brexit related stuff
what the [ __ ] is this where's the line
start for the fast food
uh let's watch some of these man [ __ ] it
man
yeah that's pretty impressive how do you
do that
parked on top of another car
stopping before entering a 70 mile per
hour highway causing me to fear for my
life
[Music]
oh is the person in front of him
stopping for some reason
what is happening
what
okay i mean that was not bad was it
seemed worse
165 miles per hour
sick
yeah i was fully expecting him to die
at the end of that video half sunder
[Music]
did anyone find that video um
i'll use it with the driveway
oh my god
whoa
oh my goodness whoa
oh in the [ __ ]
that's a full sound that's a full sun
moment
how is nothing
supposed to bend
how is that even possible
i thought those things are supposed to
what
how i don't know
that's crazy
cam says the sub is his worst nightmare
oh you have car phobia cam yeah
i get it
what is that bro
it's kanye west
oh [ __ ] okay so this i'm not aware of so
what is this ian
i don't really know he was walking
around
germany with this on i think i believe
it was italy maybe both but this one
specifically i believe is italy he's
been not spotted all over europe lately
with with this particular mask
that one and then there's another one
too
do you think it's because he didn't like
his new haircut
maybe
you want to show it
yeah yeah for sure let's see it
there i got it
yeah interestingly i've recognized this
guy from somewhere what do you think
once again proof that kanye is watching
our show
so true
undoubtedly a friend
i'm sorry for all those mean things i've
said about you
mr west or yay as of today he legally
changed his name to ya he's no longer
kanye kanye yep this is literally from
[ __ ] my [ __ ] up
no this is wild
he also doesn't have a middle name
either our last name just yay
dude this is wild man that does not look
intentional
what's your take on this ian you love
everything kanye does
that is not true
we've had many discussions but okay
i mean it's not exactly the best haircut
but i'm sure people will be walking
around with that very soon yeah
i have a theory sure um his necklace is
saint and that's the name of one of his
kids so maybe his kid gave him the
haircut
that's a pretty good theory to be honest
i mean it looks like a child
or an extremely brutal diss if you paid
a lot for it
this is what i was trying to do for you
ethan we were going to be ahead of the
curve and then
kind of beat us right i was trying to
line you up yeah again he watches
he got that uh
i i don't know if this is like a mean
joke but i was gonna say and i say this
with the huge asterisks and with peace
and love but he got that chemotherapy
cut
i mean it does kind of look like that
he looks like
to me it's the
like schizophrenic heroin addicts on
living on the streets going to the bar
and be like yo make it look like i
okay i don't even joke about cancer it's
too horrible but disease
yo barber make me look like a schizo
heroine addict say no more
say no more fam
dude that that's one of the worst
haircuts of all time it must have been
his son right i'm telling you it's gotta
be
it's gotta be yeah because like a
professional couldn't possibly emulate
this no
no well he could just do it he could
have just done himself yeah
that's true why'd you send me this love
i don't get it
i can't like
it looks like that in the back oh oh oh
yeah
oh [ __ ] love what is this you're helping
him in sweden
what the hell yeah we met up the other
day oh sick just on a mcdonald's uh is
that your daniel side gig is that your
side hustle you as they yeah i just
automated console people there yeah
everyone some fiko with kanye well love
was saying it might have been inspired
by
the
it's the one that was the picture from
the back looks
yeah there you go there you go i see
that
how did zach uncode that is there any
intel i feel like he's got to be right
about the kid yeah
you're not so sure
well i mean i'm just i'm taking it out i
think it's great i mean it does look
like a little kid
did it
i mean i put that in my hair one time
where's the other mask i want to see his
other mask he's cruising is there a
theory why he's doing this is he making
some kind of statement about race is he
trying to stand anonymous is he just
tripping balls
what are you cut to me what do i know
i'm looking at ian i know he's cutting
around all of them around he's obviously
addressing you i mean ian you don't act
like you're not the one that cares the
most about kanye here right
i don't know man he's walking around
with a mask on i don't know okay you
don't have any theory i'm sure you
thought about it
nope okay he doesn't want to get
cancelled by the freaks
again not that literally just don't know
life was like a box of chocolates what
the [ __ ] is that man
you never know what you're going to get
oh this is his other one yeah this so he
wore this um i believe to perform at a
wedding
the night prior
he's doing weddings
maybe as a friend
maybe it was the squid games
kanye's life is so wild man i just want
to sit home and play video games and
spend time with my wife and kid and you
got people like kanye
whose wife is so wild
it was the wedding of the son of the uh
i believe the ceo of louis vuitton
yeah oh
that's a big money favor yes sir yes sir
the son of mr louis vuitton yes sir
whatever you want sir
[Music]
[ __ ] that
you gotta do favors for these people
because they're so [ __ ] rich and have
so much i hate that jet
by the way if uh louis vuitton needs a
[Music]
anything a podcast or anything we'll
we'll ju you say chub we say hello
but don't you does that rub you wrong
kanye west
the independent thinker
mr louis vuitton says jump for me and he
said yes yes yes
whatever you want i'll come perform at
your wedding
well it wasn't a great performance
either so
oh maybe it was a
how do you know that is there a video
there was video well come on he uh he
messes up the lyrics too
one of his songs he's just kind of
off-key too
does it bother you that he did this
wedding or am i the only one
no
i feel like there's too much we don't
know could have helped him out early in
his career it could have been a
early kindness louis vuitton yeah i mean
okay
he's in the fashion a lot so maybe
if uh if uh mommy wojinski asked me to
do something for i'd be like anything
you need mommy machinski you got it
anything you milky
mommy
mommy wojcinski
kanye performing flashing lights
last night uh
[Music]
that sounds fine to me
it was a runaway was where he uh he kept
messing up on i mean that's amazing
party and don't get me wrong
but
damn
is it possible as a body devil because
like that's what mf doom used to do
he would always wear masks and we didn't
feel like performing you just send out
body doubles with the mask on
could be
like
that's the genius and then if this
[ __ ] cruise around europe with
this other mask
that guys could be in wyoming chilling
playing final fantasy 14
just like me it's the move man
some people are spamming channel five i
guess uh he put out a new video
yeah sounds good to me that's for
members
oh oh well i don't know if he wants me
blasting out yeah no it's it's
members-only content
that i knew about that earlier today and
i looked and it's not on his what
did he put out
something interesting we don't know uh
it looked like it was at a uh anti-covid
rally here in la i can't get enough of
those
man's man babies uk construction workers
love to dress up as a baby
yes so
i guess zach did some deep research
my first thing
was that this is for sure fake when i
watched it but zach swears that this is
a real guy my name is phil i looked into
it i couldn't find anything debunking it
so i mean
plus the channel seems legit it's like a
construction channel
no
why the [ __ ] would a construction
channel upload a video about baby fetish
oh he did
andrew did it upload it uh publicly it
just wasn't showing up on his channel
yet oh did it just must have just gone
on four minutes ago so let's watch this
then we'll watch andrews
um
yeah so
he loves to dress up as a baby you're
right there is other construction what
the [ __ ] it's very bizarre you go from
how to drill to one of our workers dress
up like baby and gets his diaper changed
gotta get this clicks swear to god it's
other construction videos
yeah it's called on the tools it's like
a uk
channel
like this like uh it's such this is part
of the gig dude dressing up like a baby
[ __ ] well
it lines up with the color story about
the bowling pin it's like macho on the
job
beta
i just like to sit in them i support
phil's lifestyle choice
i found out you like to just as a baby
obviously
together for about a year oh i think
it's really nice
my kind of feeling i mean i i believe
there's people like this
in the world it just seems like they're
acting
i like to pee in them but also why the
[ __ ] would you put this out there he's a
uk construction worker can you imagine
what this guy's gonna deal with going
back to a construction job
this is normal [ __ ] in the uk dude this
is just
this video made jordan cry
[Laughter]
men
i love men
some men wear diapers as adults who's
going to change their diaper other men
other men are going to change their
diaper that's who
being a baby man being an adult baby is
no joke man
people in the chat saying it's fake yeah
it's got to be fake come on now
you ever changed an adult diaper a big
fat guy works all day that's a big poop
that's no joke man you think a woman
could change that diaper no it's a man
that's a man's job it's a man's job to
change a man's diaper that's an old job
not the other stuff
it's just not me at the moment
yeah there's no [ __ ]
my favorite thing about being phil's
mummy is caring for him it's not dodgy
but then like why did they create this
that's what i'm saying why if it was
fake no it's like tlc where they fake
all that [ __ ] i guess i'll answer my own
question yeah
they would spend money on a man-sized
crib
they're construction workers it's easy
for me that's a good investment for the
show let's throw that together but how
do you get this actor bro you cannot pay
this actor enough because you're this is
[ __ ] you now bro it's really not
uh phil
likes being a baby
for me
there's nothing dodgy about my age play
but for a lot of people it is
sadly phil has been forced to keep his
there's nothing dodgy about h-play a man
should be able to express himself
pair
infantilism
infantilism that's right the name of uh
men are beautiful people who actually
act like this here's an article that
says the video highlights how modern men
are increasingly becoming soft
feminized and stripped away of their
masculinity
what the [ __ ] a strip this is like a
jordan peterson stripped away from their
masculinity exactly how the global is
planned this video highlights how modern
men are
becoming soft
feminized stripped away of their
masculinity
men need to be men
oh no
and when i don't wanna and when i make a
giant poopy in my diaper i expect a man
to change my diaper
a giant man-sized poop in my diaper
it doesn't even fit i have a blowout
every night
okay jordan's got so much play time in
this article lifestyle choice is a
secret as he's afraid to tell his
closest friends yeah except until now
but everybody in the world is having to
hide my lifestyle living as a baby i
don't want it to affect my work i don't
want people to think i'm a weirdo
to me it's just normal
bruh
that dude eat more than milk
i never really uh got to enjoy my
childhood because we moved around a lot
uh he's really selling it and i think
that's where the age play comes
to be honest to probably still do it
[Music]
phil believes that age play brings him
and his partner together
as well as giving him a sense of
happiness he struggles to find anywhere
else
[Music]
my goal with this is by showing myself
off to the world it will make it seem
more normal and
maybe make people less judgmental
what i do when i regress to being a
child is i color books i watch kids
films play with children's toys
it takes away all the stress of being an
adult i'd have to worry about bills
guys so [ __ ] like i'm sure there are
people like this but it's like takes
away the stress of being an adult it's
like damn your parents it's like society
is
we need to do better
nothing wrong with them i mean hey
i'm not here to kink shame
but uh
can we can we shame some people we can
shame right is there no shame is that oh
definitely what about people that are
into kids
sure
that he's not hurting anyone no this guy
specifically i'm not saying but i'm
saying there are definitely some out
there
well that's not a kink that's like an
actual [ __ ]
it's like an actual criminal i wouldn't
call pedophilia a kink true
in fact just saying it makes me feel
horrible
but
i just have to worry about someone that
like thinks [ __ ] can we shame them
someone who likes eating [ __ ] or being
[ __ ] on her
well i think they like being shamed i
think that's the whole point
dude i'm [ __ ] myself
[Laughter]
his urgency is so genuine in that
soundbite children worry about
[Music]
yes
come on this is unreal
no
it's definitely not real so usually i
would make sure you guys are just haters
but why do you say it's not real just i
can't
because this was a thing because this
was a famous video and a lot of people
looked into it
like half of our audience has seen this
before and was saying oh yeah everybody
knows this is fake okay oh yeah it's
fake wait so zach what kind of research
did you do what are you where did you
everybody knows where did you see it's
fake where did you point me where's the
sign when you're switching to me
zach was assigned to research this video
and determine if it's fake or not listen
zach represents my research team
clearly he made a mistake it's not his
fault
so you taking the blame for this baby as
always
yes
we don't plan to so it's kind of like
being a parent
but without the pain of giving birth
i personally think that age play adds a
whole new dimension to our relationship
it makes us stronger yeah we love each
other i'm gonna stop taking this video
seriously it's fake right yeah it's fake
okay
sorry zacky i don't see any evidence
though
i'm just saying where's the proof
why the [ __ ] he's right he's right
there's no proof it's just people saying
it's fake yeah that is where's the proof
where's the that's two mondays in a row
you got god
where's the proof he's right where
there's no evidence
as a defense attorney i don't see any
[ __ ] evidence here
the construction video is real and the
island boys are [ __ ] fire
you heard it here my dudes
all right let's watch me some channel
five
but zack's right do you have any have
you found any evidence
because i found this article saying that
it was released by this forum
to basically spread awareness about that
whatever [ __ ] calls i just sent
the jordan peterson calls
oh
it was released by dudes to satirize
beta males
sort of yeah wait
yo this is the [ __ ] my favorite type
of
channel 5 videos first obligatory upvote
for my boy
hollywood anti-vaxx rally this is
premium [ __ ] content my friends
yeah lately i can't get enough of these
anti-vaxxers i mean they're just so far
down the meme hole
and i don't think anything can ever pull
them out
except death basically
i mean it's too late for them
but here we go excuse me are you
vaccinated that's
mobility mary
yo that's [ __ ] mobility mary
excuse me are you vaccinating or
excuse me
zach can't can we get a little excuse me
sir oh it's a little different
excuse me are you vaccinations yeah yeah
it's a little yeah maybe it's her sister
oh man can you imagine
mary was that there i do and it's she's
in hot she's in l.a mobility harriet
mobility sherry
i do i do
[Music]
uh hate to to say this but i'm
pretty cool say it
oh i know what you're gonna do don't do
it i know what you're gonna say wait how
go ahead don't say she died i think
mobility mary is long gone hey how did
you figure how did you find that well
she was an older lady who drove around
her mobility scooter in the middle of
the street all the time um
wait are you just so you don't know
first no of course i don't know okay i
thought you were saying you were like no
no no no this is my educated guess yeah
she could be dead but that's different
than being like i know she's dead well
also
her channel is called the ghost of
mobility mary well that's why everyone
thinks she's dead
i think she's dead
because she was an ill old lady who
drove around in the middle of the street
on her mobility scooter all the time
i'm sure there's a there's a bike lane
in heaven that she's terrorizing right
now
oh my god
anyway let's watch this
excuse me are you vaccinated god that's
such mobility mary bud [ __ ] you i am
absolutely
disgusted with what's going on here in
los angeles we need to take these guys
out that close-up is like just it does
so much work
it does so much work they're all
indoctrinated with this chinese
communist fascist narrative and you know
what
we're not going to have it absolutely
not but let's dig on the team kill their
cash flow and that's going to kill them
actually i would like to see them
publicly hanging in the town square dude
this looks like the intro to a twisted
sister music video if we're not we're
not going to take it
11 l.a fascists she literally just
calling for
murdering of public officials can you do
that
eleven well i guess she's saying she
wants to see eleven la fascists will not
dictate our lives you know what's weird
is
vaccine and mass mandates are
overwhelmingly popular
amongst everybody it has like 60 to 70
percent of all americans supporting it
but if you look on the news and you
watch media all you see is these [ __ ]
anti-mask freaks cut kicking up a storm
and like they are so far in the minority
um that it's just it's so [ __ ]
annoying to deal with them
you know
70 percent are in favor of vaccine and
mass mandates
please take off your mask it's actually
encouraging to know that
there's some sanity in the world in the
town square
oh my god
with andrew callahan
good morning america you're watching
channel 5 news we're here in hollywood
california on the corner of hollywood
vine where there is a rally to save
america by saving
what is it what's the name of the rally
hey what's what's the name of this rally
again unity march what's the catch
phrase for this march
let the lions lose who are the lions
we're the lions who are the sheep oh all
the [ __ ] idiots that like put [ __ ] in
their arm what's your instagram handle
it's liberty is dope one
channel five live worldwide hollywood
invites wait this guy's been like every
one of his videos
today and all day forward
dude all of these people are coaching
was making this point the other day the
usual suspect dude these people have
money that's what's crazy a lot of them
that like how else is this guy traveling
the country just going to protest all
day like he doesn't have a [ __ ]
normal job well he could be yeah i mean
he's older so he could be retired he
could be on social security right have a
pension i i suppose it could be i
wouldn't say he i don't i doubt he's
rich and well educated i don't think
that they're like rich rich but they're
not like the working poor yeah like they
they have the leisure time
to waste their [ __ ] time doing this
all day you know you know they say that
boredom is the number one killer of the
uh uh retired so right oh you're true
yeah we love you we love the elderly
getting out there and we're living an
active lifestyle
exactly this is good for him unless he
catches covet of course then he dies
one of the toughest vaccine mandates in
the nation coming to los angeles the
city council approved a measure
requiring proof of full vaccination to
enter many oh by the way yeah i went to
uh dinner the other night
with the family and they required uh
proof of vaccination to get in
and i was like [ __ ] fantastic let's
go i went to lunch yesterday same thing
i need to actually start carrying around
my [ __ ] cart oh i have it on my wall
on my wallet it's on my
phone there's awesome oh just a picture
of it sufficient yeah you can get the
city of la will will email you a link oh
and you can download it so i have like
the wallet on apple here i'll show you i
love that it's so [ __ ] nice yeah it
gives you a qr code like yeah it sure
looks like that
sick i gotta do that that's way better
than carrying around so nice it's legit
like three questions name
social security or something like that
yes for and you get it right away
but you know they're fair they go you
can sit outside or you can sit inside
but you have to be vaccinated inside
it's like okay so you've got an option
still if you're
don't want to get the
you know the
businesses eligible students in the
nation's second largest school district
will now be required to get vaccinated
against the coronavirus it comes amid
soaring pandemic cases across the
country and they're putting on crt it's
time to just move move on and move away
yes yes move away
i love california i love la
there's a lot to you know criticize but
la
california's particularly has been on
top of this pandemic since the [ __ ]
beginning the first state to go into
lockdown we have held our numbers
fairly low always done the good thing
as a whole
and now leading the way with vaccine
mandates
[ __ ] love it
because listen we gotta force these hogs
we have to make life very uncomfortable
for these hogs to [ __ ] get vaccinated
i'm not in favor of like kicking down
someone's door i'm not in favor of
forcing vaccine on somebody to walk
around the streets you know but like if
you want to use a business
you gotta get vaccinated baby
let's go
wait i don't want my kid messed up i
don't want them learning about critical
race theory i don't want them to worry
about that
they still pass these these mandates on
these kids they still put it in schools
we have to take our kids out wait what
is pb
probably
oh jesus christ bro
oh
that's a beautiful shot by the way
that's that is amazing this school there
are certain people that maybe it's
better for them maybe my thing is it's
99
survival rate like what is it for from a
health 95
do you understand what you're saying
five percent of people that get the
[ __ ] virus die
how do you not understand how [ __ ]
that is
five percent means everything true
i don't think that's accurate no it's
it's way less than that but he's trying
to make it sound yeah he makes it sound
worse it's like
it's like 98 or 99 it's still which is
incredibly high because if you compare
it to the flu
that that's like point zero zero
one three or something like that takes
that five percent so like a full one or
two percent is as you've seen over seven
hundred thousand people have died in
this country alone
standpoint it's not it's a business if
we listen to pharma our cough syrup will
still have heroin in it it's a dumb did
i wish i would [ __ ] sick i'd be
hitting that [ __ ] tonight
mr [ __ ] we are going by the nazi
playbook wake up guys the vaccine
passport yeah i love this is my favorite
god i gotta decode this i gotta pause
for a minute
show me your passport show me your shots
do you uh do you want to come with rob
to america
so the they this is how desperate they
are to be oppressed
they're comparing themselves to
the genocide of the jews in europe
to not being able allowed to eat inside
of an ihop
show me your passport
vaccine they think that
only passports only existed in nazi
germany
my body is god's temple yeah right
let's see what you look like
and now i'm hitler
yo
do you see that so okay so corona
you got the number where are you looking
right in the middle the white thing oh
oh okay cool so c is the numerology
let's go right so we've added together
no way
no way six six six so what what wait
what is the first six derived it's just
66. it's the four it's the digit it's
the there's six letters oh cause there's
six ladders yes wait is there really 66
does that work out
i'm i would assume that they did the
math well don't assume but i guess yeah
let's see 30 plus 15 plus 18.
plus
15 plus
14 plus one equals 66 my dude okay and
then can someone
fact check that they got the number of
the letters correct because if this
checks out i think we need to be
concerned oh there's no such thing as
three
i mean someone could do that behind the
scenes
looks right i'll crack the code
you guys could proceed yo is anybody
worried that korea
means 666. somebody in our audience just
said numerology is actually legit though
so
that's what i'm saying this is how do
you explain the 666
a lot of weird things like that around
911 as well wait does that mean the beer
corona is
satanic right
corona beer is satanic too i like
cracking open a corona with someone why
i'm on a hot bath
i can't i can't do that anymore it's
it's proven it's mathematical yeah
is there anything else named corona that
we can write off from the world
yo the [ __ ]
corona of the sun dude
corona sun god
no like the actual physical corona it's
like part it's like the outer shadow
satan amen i think the sun itself might
be there
i got another one for you dan that
you'll corona is the artist that did the
song the rhythm of the night antichrist
amen send the hell jesus christ his name
and heaven's name
name is corona yo
send her to hell
send her to hell boys yo
90's eurobeat is satanic [ __ ] dude i
knew corona wait does she say my quran
no says something else i sharona oh yeah
said sure sent your under the hell boys
too close to corona
yeah this is the problem with this
numerology [ __ ] it's like you're gonna
write off every [ __ ] thing that has
corona in the name because it's satanic
coronavirus is one word by the way
so oh
small loop what do those add up to
probably not 666. damn i'm sure i'm sure
we can make a number and divide it by
something to get 666. is it rona season
all right let's move on from this
dumbass
just like wearing a yellow star on your
arm if you're too brainwashed and too
stupid to see that a mask and a vaccine
are not going to protect you from
fascism you know what i've got some
swampland in florida for you what does
that mean
that means
i'm buying swampland in florida that's
like the stupidest thing you could
possibly do what kind of a question is
that dude come on because it sinks under
the mud or whatever yeah it's like it's
not an investment would you rather live
in wuhan china or portland oregon
neither
you have to pick at a studio apartment
in either city i i wouldn't i would not
it's would you rather it's got a picture
i don't care i'm not answering that
question because i would rather not do
either one of them [ __ ] joe local
celebrity here yeah man hey i'm not
gonna lie man i would i definitely [ __ ]
with donald trump heavies not
discriminating against the black people
with this vaccine and if it wasn't for
him edd ppp it wouldn't it wouldn't
exist
so wait did you just reference edp
edpp what is that well ppp is the loan
program i know but what is the edp just
another uh program that happened that
[ __ ] that's what i was thinking
actually by the way i was a super sad no
i was catching up on the whole edp
saga yeah did he ever get arrested for
all that
i don't think so because i think
i think the guys who conducted it
botched it
because they turned out to be super
the whole story was so crazy edp was the
sports
youtuber who was like super raunchy and
crazy i mean i always thought he was
funny he called into our show a long
time ago man
and he got caught
trying to pick up a 13 year old girl
in a sting
but like the logs of him flirting with
the third child girl is the craziest
[ __ ] when he opened the dms when he
started chatting with this girl
he sent her a picture of his [ __ ] in the
toilet
like early on in the courting process
he was like hey what you doing and sent
a picture of his [ __ ]
why
swear in the foot i swear to [ __ ] god
he did that
it was crazy
anyway hey [ __ ] with donald trump
heavies not discriminating against the
black people with this vaccine and it
wasn't for him edd ppp
yeah that's food stamps right no that's
uh
yeah there's too many unemployment yeah
it's a welfare thing exist
so actually donald trump actually
made a big impact
[Music]
[Applause]
medical freedom freedom this beautiful
country we stand for
there's so much on my mind
we are patient advocates not federal
henchmen
oh okay what is the picture
on the bottom one it just looks like
some royalty-free
images
today
yes in jesus mighty name amen
in jesus name amen it
i am 17 years old and i live in orange
county and i'm here to protest for
freedom stand up for what's right you're
a [ __ ] sheep the [ __ ] outta here
calling me [ __ ] hey this is
zoytown [ __ ]
again it's like the most unoppressed
people in the history of the world
the
i just i love the perceived
the shackles the oppression
i can't go eat at ihops inside i can sit
outside but i want to sit inside it's
hot
i am oppressed
there's freedom for the world
i love too that that guy is like in that
clip he's like this is our town
[ __ ] but he just said he's from
orange county he's like you only [ __ ]
literally
that was actually an old video he's at
huntington beach in that video oh it is
his oh he found the same guy
right well why is he coming to our town
to do this could stick to huntington
beach dude yeah he'll be fine no one
will ask him to wear that so good the
whole [ __ ] out of hollywood
the whole orange county
l.a
dynamic is so weird because like they're
right next to each other
la as you know a bastion for liberalism
and orange county is just maga [ __ ]
[ __ ] country
it's a lot less than it used to be but
there is still a lot of that i don't
know man i went down to make a video
with idubbbz on a boat and it was like
yeah it was there the flags yeah right
forget it yeah it was like mega flags
yeah no huntington beach in areas like
that for sure orange county as a whole
though i think actually voted for
hillary and biden in the last two
elections
which was like unthinkable
when i was growing up because yeah it
used to be a conservative bastion but
it's it's a lot less so now but there's
definitely like you said huntington
beach and areas like that are yeah i
mean when we were there nobody gave a
[ __ ] about
masks or anything yeah we were like the
only people
and they were looking at us like what
betas okay okay okay i took hand by
there the other week and i told them the
same thing like we're all gonna we're
gonna get stared at for in a
were you the only ones with bats i think
so yeah there was only a few people like
in the restaurants that had but that was
it because the people there are like
openly
it's not just like they'll roll their
eyes they'll like get in your face and
yeah you know start yelling at you if
you're wearing a mask yeah they asked me
what happened to freedom
freedom to wear mouth only goes one way
it only goes one way no they were like
oh you look familiar do i know you from
somewhere like i don't think so they're
like well i can't tell with your mask
it's like oh yeah bro where everyone
that's crazy
[ __ ]
take it try and jake
what had brought you to the white lives
matter rally in hb
i heard the clan was going to be there i
don't like the [ __ ] clan as someone
who's semitic or half semitic you know i
i don't like that [ __ ]
he is i disavow the semetics
we don't like this semetics we disavow
it
whatever half he's got we don't want
we give this back to the white people
and i went there and all i saw was
people ganging up on people with
american flags and i didn't stand for
that who'd you come here with
i came here with kelly right here
legend assassinated by the clintons
dude this is the dream team [ __ ] up
[ __ ] [ __ ] you where are you
[ __ ] your life by the way these people
are
are like horrible too it's like why are
you even you first of all you look so
stupid these people aren't serious don't
take them so seriously and you just you
look psychotic too getting in their face
and telling them [ __ ] your life kill
yourself like i guess people refer to
these people as antifa i don't know
they're literally flying an antifa flag
right in the background it looks like a
tongue in mouth like
yeah
so i guess these antifa if people didn't
even care if they wouldn't pay attention
them nobody would [ __ ] care or even
talk about it
and some some stuff these i think
there's uh counter protesting is good
but like this guy is like such a dumbass
straight
up amigos
uh we're up here in hollywood and you
know it's a big day can you describe
what this flag is and exactly what this
is is a four banger four bangers four
flags on one pole so if you go up to the
top
before banger that's a new technique
these guys leveled up
benson trump
flag and that flew in the capital of dc
on january 6th
to stop the steel flag this second up
top
you know what i believe totally in your
freedoms i do bre you got to do what you
have to do but
i guys i'm sorry but
someone going people are defending
antifa i'm not i have no problem with
antifa
i don't think you need to get in their
face and say i hope you [ __ ] die
straight up homie just some dude
flying a floor what do you call it a
floor bang a four banger flag it's not
that serious is my point
okay
thank you peace and love
someone said ethan should watch a
recent cnn video about the conservatives
contradicting themselves when it comes
to refugees yeah i mean it's
it's all manufactured take the vaccines
i did it it's good take the vaccines but
you got no that's okay that's all right
you got your freedoms
but i happened to take the vaccine do
you still support trump even though
trump was heavy on the vaccine uh i
don't think he was too heavy on the
vaccine he was just trying to uh tell
people what may be available and to make
their own decision i don't think he was
forcing them he wasn't offering them
money he wasn't offering to pay their
tuition he wasn't offering millions of
dollars he wasn't in free donuts he
wasn't offering him beer milkshakes
you know for free hamburger free
something you know just it's crazy and
it's proven that it has creepy crawlers
in it it has pieces of metal
crawlers in the vaccine
it's not like a caterpillar or something
i remember it as a toy from when we were
kids it's like a gross bug creepy
crawlers it's things with tentacles and
they like you try to move together it's
like they're a family of uh of uh
satanic little particles yeah
so he this is a man that thinks satanic
little particles known as creepy callers
and the vaccine we don't mean to be
screaming in his face i hope you [ __ ]
die for real it's just not that serious
is my point
i think the is on the creepy crawler
agenda uh i think it's to depopulate
it's things that are bad for people kids
grow in tails kids growing up with
animal hair it's for the new world order
i think they want to get us all on the
world um you know in the um
money system so i know it's about the
new world order it's to get it to
depopulate media beef media fiasco media
fiasco they're yelling
hold on
hold on oh [ __ ] we're going viral we're
going viral
all right we're walking away
oh [ __ ] we're going viral we're going
viral we're going viral oh what's up man
we're going viral
viral you going viral
are you going viral we're going viral
hopefully
hopefully i got a bunch of fights today
don't air this at all please we'll get
in big time trouble all right guys we
are in hollywood love the size there we
go what do you guys do out here what are
you what's going on walking around
talking to people saying what's up after
a hectic few weeks on the road okay you
like the sixers uh
january sixers
[Laughter]
[Music]
was that a gimbal look how stable your
man is right now yeah this is pretty
stable if you're watching this
is
i know but oh am i supposed to know who
the [ __ ] this guy is
they they just put up a
chiron or whatever it says maggots
brother he's a maggot reporter yeah
i was not there were you there i was
there yeah it was a great time i don't
know what that means to people does that
mean i'm a bad guy am i a bad guy for
going no
people think i am i don't think you're a
bad guy how can you be a bad guy with a
nice suit like that right that's what
i'm saying how do you feel right now
we're on the walk of fame do you think
that you're ever going to have a star of
your own this guy's like the end never
thought about that he's walking
backwards he's getting better all right
somewhere else i hope this is the
beginning of a villain arc in andrew's
story where they're dual reporting uh
constantly part of this industry anymore
when you say hollywood's going down the
drain uh what type of stuff do you mean
well if you think about it everything
that you
watch on tv is pretty much propaganda
rituals so funny i'm walking backwards
like 10 blocks there you go i'm not
going to be part of hollywood what's
your favorite tv show
uh probably american horror story that's
like the most satanic show until it is
but you watch it
to understand what they're doing
it comes down to rituals
i don't want to say what group but they
they do it and it's been passed down
from thousands you know hundreds of
years of generations and he's talking
about it they used to do it back then
shout out the
keemstar is like i'm sorry
somebody jamar is like did somebody say
something
i'm listening yes
okay uh keemstar
so can you describe exactly what the
ritual is
i believe it's um
they take a baby
they torture it they put in a a this
bull right and they
they uh they drain the blood and then
someone's why are you laughing
if you believe that crazy high off it
probably you know they're drinking blood
from children what's his little nose guy
he's blowing the devil banging the devil
i mean like probably music video bro
you're talking about drinking baby blood
like
far leap
i'm almost positive that's not an ahs
in any of the seasons
did you say he saw american horror story
was his favorite yeah i i thought he was
pulling that from the show saying that
that's what he's watching it for but i
haven't seen that in the show oh yeah no
no we need to prove it that's the
problem i can't i'm not there yet it's
just people are going to uprise
and
i think a war could be coming right now
it's an information spiritual war but i
think it's going to be a physical war
someday yeah and who do you think by the
way
andrew definitely out reported this guy
he is just like basically just simping
for andrew right now just gushing
telling all he won this battle
easy
two sides are gonna be patriots versus
the lip tarts or the unvaccinated versus
the vaccine listen listen to me listen
to me listen to me even hillary clinton
said on national tv somebody's gonna hit
and we're gonna break that big glass no
in the sky i said huh i know we have
she's talking about a woman getting
elected
is that just a metaphor for a woman
becoming president what does he think it
is i think he me i think he thinks
there's a glass ceiling in the sky
that's going to fall down on us
still not shattered that highest and
hardest glass ceiling but someday
someone will and hopefully sooner than
we might think
awesome they took that literally on
national tv we're in the [ __ ] dome
yes this [ __ ] [ __ ] is no way
that's
that's deep deep deep in the meme hall
because they try to break the ice wall
that's on the out layer that's keeping
us inside you think the earth is flat do
i think i know you should go read
genesis anyway
why aren't you down here why aren't you
covering oh no they found that cnn
could you support the charity what's up
what's up
hey man what's going on what's on your
mind
not much for sure how do you feel about
cnn
this is so good
andrew's so amazing he's he's so good
big fan what media do you
trust i trust independent thinkers i
trust critical thinkers
i trust
blaze media
the daily liar what about channel 5 what
about channel 5
dude this is his biggest fan he's
following him everywhere these are this
thing is like this guy
he just wants attention he's a but also
he's like probably
like a
they're having fun together you know
what i'm saying like they're not that
serious
yeah he's got a four stack flag he's
flying he's just having a good [ __ ]
weekend and he's cruising with andrew
they're dogs
yeah
yeah by the way when the civil war
breaks out these are what the soldiers
are gonna look like on the opposing side
so
get ready
five what these nuts
gotti are you well then the great oh no
way we found that these nuts guys
no
that's the deez nuts guy
is that really him yeah this is hard
hitting journalism i have to go back
what does the deez nuts guy think about
the vaccine that's the question
the daily wire what about channel five
what about channel five
channel five what these nuts
[Music]
gotti are you welding the great hell
yeah how you been doing wilvin oh oh
i've been good i've been silent how do
you feel about kobets
did you take the uh vaccine
took the vaccine so i like it though
there you go the deez nuts guys is
[ __ ] on
[Applause]
he's right there next to the counter
protesters being like i took
i can't believe he just randomly popped
up in this video this is amazing this is
the perfect juxtaposition here uh
between these nuts guys
and uh lipstick on the teeth lady
it's cool
so [ __ ] you la city council go [ __ ]
these
shots you're watching channel 5
you're watching channel 5.
these nuts
and the beast
the beast
the beast system that's like the one
percent are they worship lucifer all of
them i mean if they sell their soul
for fame they're bowing down to lucifer
that's the beast system what about if
they like have an independent following
that gets goes viral on youtube and they
have almost as much fame as like a
b-list actor that doesn't count that's
independent how do you get into the
b-system you sell your soul you sign a
contract with who typically it's the big
industries you know so they come to you
with a contract but you're signing it
with lucy
so when you sign the like the paperwork
even if it's in a pdf format on docusign
hey i don't know the exact
technical details but i know if you sign
the contract you're
signing away your soul yeah some
celebrities you think are top offenders
tom hanks
i'm
not gonna name many more names i'm just
pretty much against tom hanks
tom hanks yeah his son i mean have you
seen his son's tattoos they're pretty
luciferian chet hanks what's his son's
name i don't know i just thought he's
like covered in like illuminati dude how
is everything tying together so well the
andrew callahan universe is a giant web
[ __ ] deep with these nuts guys at the
center pulling all the strings
him up he's got like
the pyramid and
[Music]
i'm noticing you have a bernie sanders
t-shirt on
yes
you like bernie sanders um i like some
of his policies i support medicare for
all free college universal child care
universal paid family leave five weeks
paid vacation a smaller military budget
but you don't like the vaccine no
we the little people are supposed to
sacrifice ourselves be maimed and die
don't trust the [ __ ] pharma-funded
media people need to start like talking
to community members and people that
they know not lebron james or any other
uh a media member or a celebrity
celebrity who live for congress
i'm a congressional candidate
and one of the things pisses me off
about our government we have you're a
candidate
well anybody can that's not the same
the only thing he's
these officials they have no idea what
it's like to be out here
no idea no idea ted liu the guy i'm
running against he would never come
because it's so ridiculous you know
those people will finish in a hospital
you know a bunch of uneducated people
and trumpist
well just said just look at the numbers
if you're not vaccinated you will end up
in hospital you know and you eventually
die you know it's just ridiculous you
know is there a lot of people like this
in france
uh there's some you know but i think not
as bad as here yeah why do you think
it's worse here i would say the the
government has much more power in france
to enforce rules and mandates compared
to here where it's very decentralized
then you have all those states like uh
pretty good because he would not enforce
the rules to make us safer you know so
do you think there should be tighter
restrictions yep sure
yeah more mandates yep do you see that
as conflicting with constitutional
rights no
i stand with the french dude and the
deez nuts guys all the way
that was a masterful video yeah that's
good content my dudes that is good
content
wow
oh maybe some will shatners wow
wow
we have a few more calls lined up let's
see
oh my god oh no we don't
oh my goodness oh my goodness me oh wow
um
this guy really wants to talk to us
about his hair
surgery
he's trying to get hairline surgery he's
been on the he's been on the he's been
on hold for two hours
i can't believe so alex
i'm gonna tell you yes go for it man
do it simple as that yeah if you want it
go for it what's the problem
i don't know i mean well first of all
hello
hello what's up what up pimp nation
hello thank you so much for thank you so
much for taking the call absolutely i
don't know man i mean i
i it's a scary thing you know like you
know how that works right you know how
they do the the uh hair surgery yeah
they they like uh suck little hair
follicles out from the back of your head
right and then they put it on the front
no i so the one that i'm signed up for
they slice a whole little strip out of
the back of your head they open up a
nice you know squishy on the back there
and then they they pull out the uh they
pull out the hairs they have like a
whole team
sitting there chopping your hairs out
and then they put it into the holes in
your head but look at the results man
the result look at what on the screen
right now machine gun kelly the results
are sp
beautiful i mean if you got to be honest
yeah yeah he he was one of the main
reasons why i wanted to do it like his
result is probably the best that i've
ever seen dude he exactly i mean he went
from like a
from like a four to like an eight
to dating megan fox yeah exactly
remember these guys are rich do you
think i should bring like your picture
in if i say like get me as close as i
can to this
like a barber
you know how much is it going to run
that
what's the price run
so you pay per hair and pay-per-hand
it's like
yeah yeah you pay per hair and so for me
it would be
like 7 200
that's expensive but that's a that's a
life-changing pursuit i mean like if
they do a good job if you got a good
doctor i say go for it buddy if you got
the money yeah i want to take a loan out
or put yourself in debt or anything like
that but if you got the money if you
have the income disposable cash do it
bro it'll suck for a minute but you're
gonna [ __ ] feel great when it's done
all right you know what go for it i
think i'm gonna go ahead and do it i the
doctor's in newport beach i'm not gonna
shout him out i'm not getting paid um
but
i'll update i'll let you know how it
goes
and you know
contact us i'd love to see the before
and after i hope i don't give you
horrible advice and you're like fed is
all mangled and [ __ ] up
no i think it'll be fine i i trust this
guy i talked to a couple doctors
um
you have a similar kind of balding
pattern as machine gun kelly
yeah yeah i would say i mean he was
actually worse than me like i'm not that
bad now um so if i can even get close to
that then do it bro do it you're gonna
feel great do it
thank you yeah god bless you okay i hope
it's a great procedure
and who knows maybe shout out to
everyone maybe uh when uh maybe when
machine gun kelly is done or megan fox
is done with machine gun kelly maybe you
can be swooping up with that beautiful
hairline
uh
no i'm getting married in a year to my
wonderful fiance jacob
oh
well congratulations what does your
husband think or your future husband is
he in favor of it
[Applause]
yeah he said go for it yeah so i think
i'm gonna do it i wanted to do it before
the wedding so it's going to be in about
a year so if i do it now i'll be fully
grown in by then
it's a weird thing with the hair surgery
too because like
there's so many celebrities that get it
and you totally forget that they ever
were balding
unless you like specifically look
there's so many celebrities that got it
and i don't even think
like i wouldn't look at machine gun
kelly think oh he got
hair surgery there's almost no way to
tell that i'm aware of
we're like a nose job
there's a scar yeah
yeah like you get like a line in the
back your head but that's a small price
to pay small price get it dude get that
beautiful hair all right all right take
care buddy thank you hairline
caroline king out from one hairline king
to another
love our hairline kings
wait a joe rogan's car
joe are you [ __ ] serious
he got a haircut
hair transplant but that motherfucker's
bald is a goddamn
yeah that's the issue if you if it
doesn't work out
you go bold you're kind of [ __ ]
whoa that did not work out for joe there
they won the nobel prize you never see
the back of his dome
i feel like something about that picture
is making it seem a lot well yeah the
whole side of his face looks like i feel
like i've seen
not that you can't see it but like for
whatever in that it looks gnarly in that
photo but i don't think it always looks
that crazy
that was a [ __ ] flop
the dude is balder than ever
here's another one of joe
that's a pretty intense scar
yeah i don't know i kind of researched
it a couple
months ago and yeah i kind of got
i i decided not to do it i don't know
why but all the celebrities look amazing
and yeah but you know they're rich they
probably pay like hundreds of thousands
of years and joe rogan was rich when he
got it too and his hair is [ __ ] his
dome looks yeah so that's i think it can
just sometimes not work maybe but that
doesn't just shitload of testosterone
make you bald like this [ __ ]
that's true so much weird chemicals and
[ __ ] his body is just screaming agony
it's ejecting hairs from his head
i think
if anything that's
yeah i think tasty taking uh
testosterone can make you bald
which is ironic but true
like oh you want to be more man bald
um
testosterone is all kinds of weird [ __ ]
to your body
well guys how long we've been going
we've been going
[Music]
two hours 45 minutes wow
um
what was the deal i saw this on my feed
i wasn't sure what's the deal that it's
just like boomer cringe energy what do
you think is the number one contributing
factor she's trying to she's like oh so
you like watching people dance i i guess
i was trying to interpret it because i
included her channel she's got a bunch
of these videos
yeah i think they drove because she's
like oh you like watching people dance
on tick tock that's all you care about
well then i'm going to do that and wake
you up
there were a lot of videos like this for
a while a couple years ago where people
would be saying a message and dancing
and i think she just took it she's late
nothing heats up earth almost like
jet fuel pesticides lead and other
chemicals too do you think it's a
coincidence that the military emission
man
oh she's a comedian
okay
let's try another one i think is our
global god
what is our most powerful religion
it might not be what you think it is let
me guess it's money profit
oh how did i know
money is our god
is she in the same forest as uh
no such thing as
there's no such thing as this
[ __ ] come descending from the
heavens with his black wings
there is no such thing as of coincidence
you may think she's dancing right now
but she is actually in hell surrounded
by the demons of money there's no such
thing as the coin
contact with a divine being
usually that person has a d and b's
because something about a wingy ding i'm
just not sure that this joke has that
much legs yeah and there's like a lot
but i know it's like the cool thing to
take a dump on billionaires right now
but our billionaire is really the only
product it's always seem like it's a
joke like i know it says she's a
comedian
i guess the joke is just the dancing
matched with uh serious stuff but it's a
lot of just
do it like 20 times are you a good
person i like to think of myself as a
good person like the other day i brought
my own bags to the grocery store because
i'm better than you
and i had the guy bag my groceries and
when i got home i looked in the grocery
bag and there was my dirty underwear
i had left in the bag somehow so
the grocery store guy had to bag
groceries over my dirty underwear and
that's coming you know maybe this whole
good person bad
i'm not sure i follow that one lady yeah
uh
tick tock fever dream
can you tell me what's happening in this
video
you don't need that
she wants the donuts she eats all the
donuts
and now she's alive she's grinding up
wheat
she went in the forest got eggs shaking
the what the [ __ ] is going on
farting what the f
dude
dude what
the title is funny family is this kids
content yeah this seems like it's for
babies it's just youtube kids content
yeah
i mean i agree the plot is a little hard
to follow
well she's she ate the donuts and she's
trying to make them from scratch to
replace them
she's cooking them on this is the kind
of content that has like 10 trillion
views on youtube though these people are
like richer
they got more money than bezos
d i bet you it is on youtube yeah for
sure let's see
wow
epic that's there's quite a narrative
that was
weaved there moving all right
well
that's about it guys
i had a good one
oh my goodness these are still not
pooping so i'm trying to get home
again i mean he's pooping but he's still
constantly like he'll go a few days
without pooping it's just very stressful
and then he gets upset yeah
that sucks it really sucks i've been
massaging the farts out of him
with sagi we're giving him some kind of
laxative now that the doctor gave us
which it's a little [ __ ] up when you
like give him a ton of laxatives like
two days in a row and he's still not
[ __ ] it's like what the [ __ ] is
going on in there she gave him some
[ __ ] chipotle am i right i did give
him some of that
some of that spicy uh
yeah he probably would [ __ ] his pants
just like daddy you wanna go make
diarrhea with daddy
we can go make diarrhea together buddy
all right guys well uh have a great week
happy monday
and we will see you as usual
on
thursday slash wednesday for members
right thank you to all of our members by
the way every one of you
absolutely
every last one except keemstar who has a
membership just to downvote our member
uploads good point not him everyone but
you not you
it's like a romeo juliet
anyways
love you guys
thanks for watching
[Music]
you